passer tout de suite au témoins du jour
on va parler de David ALID le fils aîné
de Johnny ALID qui vient d'annoncer la
sortie de son autobiographie un livre
choc dans lequel il souhaite remettre
toutes les choses à leur place de quoi
inquiéter Laeticia parce que c'est là
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre je peux
vous dire faut pas rester au milieu
quelles sont les relations actuelles
entre les différents membres de la
famille de quoi cette autobiographie
va-t-elle parler ce soir nous sommes
avec myiam
Palomba Renault corler le dernier
photographe de Johnny et Roland Perez
avocat est très proche de syv
la maman de David on est très content
qu'il soit là Roland et bien sûr les
autres aussi ils vont répondre à toutes
nos questions et on va vous expliquer
cette histoire puisqueapparemment la
guerre va reprendre de plus belles petit
rap et ils sont avec nous juste après
regardez merci
encore en 2017 la France perdit l'un des
plus grands monuments de la chanson
française Johnny Halid est mort il avait
74 ans un décès tragique qui a
bouleversé la famille du chanteur en
créant une véritable bataille juridique
notamment autour de l'héritage entre
laticia et les enfants de Johnny hidday
Laura et David latia a saisi aussi la
justice américaine pour essayer de
brouiller les pistes et alors que David
ALID s'est toujours montré plutôt
discret l'homme a décidé à 57 ans de
sortir son autobiographie où il se
confesse comme rarement un livre
événement apparaître prochainement où il
entend remettre les choses à leur place
alors nouveau livre trahison clan la
guerre autour de Johnny alidday
relancé merci Miriam d'être avec nous
merci Renaud et merci Roland d'être là
déjà Miriam bon davidid c'est bien sûr
le fils de Joh idé et de Sylvie bartan
j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs davidid très
sympa il va parler de quoi dans son
livre alors c'est un livre
d'introspection qui va être publié le
d'introspeo j'ai baffoué c'est
çaou on l' refait c'est un livre
d'introspection qui qui va être publié
aux éditions du Cherche Midi le le 23
novembre bon début eu et et donc
là-dessus il va il a on il y a un
communiqué qui a été qui a été donné à
la la presse où effectivement ils
expliquent quoi dans ce communiqué ils
disent que c'est un
Liv je pense en des semaines donc et et
quelles sont ces relations avec latia ah
bah les relations avec latia sont très
très très mauvaises enfin voilà il quand
il parle d'elle il dit l'ex-fme il évite
de parler d'elle le plus souvent
possible moi si vous voulez j'ai un
extrait que je pourrais vous lire du du
du livre comment
ça vous
voulez
dem vous voulez que je lise sinon
non ce que j'ai surlé ça va aller dé ça
sera fait comme ça on a beaucoup
débattuière et fantasmer sur ma famille
donc chaque événement non événement a
été ép scruter commenter juger plus d'un
demisècle de folie médiatique
franchement qui dit mieux ce que nous
voulions garder pour nous a été offert
en place publique rien
ou presque n' n'a résisté à l'appétit du
spectacle et à sa passion d'exhiber rien
n'est demeuré
sacré c'est le prix du ton de la
célébrité pour ma part je le trouve
exorbitant voilà c'est donc dans le
livre d'un
rose meilleur album le le livre
s'appelle meilleur album merci un peu
plus de scoop dans le bouquin que ça
hein parce que là c'est pour l'instant
c'est sous sargo alors on na pas ben non
mais ça laisse présager quand même
quelques petits règlements de compte
justement alors qu'est-ce qui justement
est-ce qu'il y a encore des conflits
entre Laétitia et David est-ce que c'est
réglé là toutes les histoires parce que
là on a alors les histoires d'héritage
sont réglées depuis 2020 donc Laura elle
a touché 2,6 millions pour abandonner
toutes les poursuites judiciaires elle a
également elle elle garde les droits de
la chanson Laura et elle a récupéré
quelques quelques affaires personnelles
de de Johnny quant à quant à David lui
il s'était désisté de l'héritage il
avait refusé voilà de de de prendre quoi
que ce soit certainement parce qu'il
avait ça tu pourra peut-être nous en
dire plus mais de prendre aussi les
dettes de son père et il ne voulait plus
parler de cette histoire voilà les
choses sont là et pour l'instant c'est
effectivement Laeticia et ses filles qui
sont les héritières de tout le
patrimoine qui reste de Johnny ALID donc
un Roland oui en fait David il a voulu
au départ protéger évidemment sa sœur
lui mais protéger surtout ses ses deux
demi-sœur même s'il n'a pas de contact
aujourd'hui avec elle il voulait les
protéger il voulait en sorte que cette
succession reste en France et que ce
soit pas sous ces ces ces différent
trust qui avait été fait aux États-Unis
où on ne savait pas qui faisait quoi
donc il a ramené effectivement cette
succession avec sa sœur en France la loi
lui a donné raison mais à partir de là
il a pas fait tout ça pour de l'argent
donc lui s'est désisté il y avait
effectivement cette cette grosse grosse
datte fiscale euh lorsqu'on accepte de
façon directe ou indirecte une
succession et bien le fisque même des
droits sur un sur des albums même des
droits sur une carrière et bien on vient
vous dire finalement vous avez accepté
indirectement cette succession donc vous
si les dettes ne sont pas payées par et
bien la la femme de Johnny alidday c'est
peut-être les enfants qui vont être
amenés à à les payer donc ça il a vou
faire table ras il y a eu un protocole
d'accord mais ce protocole d'accord il
n'y a pas participé lui c'est-à-dire que
il a dit je me désiste d'c donc à partir
de là il esté lui par ce qu'on appelle
une obligation de confidentialité
d'accord il a rien pris donc David rien
rien même pas une guitare non s vraiment
Ren gu rien rien il est parti sans rien
une main devant une main derrière comme
nousand on est V moral sur uniquement
100 % mais ce droit moral il se voilà il
y a pas de ça veut dire quoi justement
le droit moral sur 100% le droit moral
c'estd que sur le sur le les chansons
qu'il a composé pour son père la musique
qu'il a composé pour son père% ex 100 %
et bien ces musiques là ne peuvent pas
être utilisées pour une publicité pour
sans son autorisation qu'elle ne soit
pas détourné de leur de leur contexte
original et sans bénéfice financier et
sans aucun bénéfice financiers absol
alors ce livre il est intitulé meilleur
album
pourquoi parce que bah c'est alors je
sais pas il me l'a pas dit
personnellement mais mais comme il fait
en fait la revue de tout ce qui s'est
passé dans sa vie j'imagine que pour lui
c'est une partition il le voit comme une
partition de de de de sa vie depuis son
enfance alors Renaud dans est-ce que ça
relance la guerre cette histoire parce
que c'est ce que tout ce que tout le
monde semble dire c'est vrai qu'on s'y
attendait pas on croyait que c'était
fini là il y a ce livre qui sort et qui
apparemment va relancer la Guer entre
laticia et David et Laura mais pour moi
c'est c'est une petite bombe parce que
finalement David il a toujours été
extrêmement élégant et publicique sur
l'histoire de sa famille il a toujours
été très classe làdessus oui et et là il
dit enfin sa vérité pas rapporté par des
journalistes ou des articles il dit les
choses à sa façon et je pense aussi que
ils ont chacun leur vérité finalement et
ils arrivent pas à se rencontrer
là-dessus alors euh justement euh
pourquoi à votre avis David a voulu
faire ça euh et le timing pourquoi
pourquoi ce timing là euh bah il il a 57
ans aujourd'hui David alidday il a
toujours été extrêmement discret
c'est-à-dire que même pendant cette
guerre de l'héritage on l'a quasiment
pas vu parler on a vu Sylvie monter un
peu au créneau on a vu évidemment
latitia Laura pardon se manifester mais
lui il est resté dans l'ombre il ne sait
absolument pas
manifesté et donc à partir de là je
pense que les éditions du Cherche Midi
font un très gros coup en lui proposant
de faire cette autobiographie d'abord il
a raison de parler lui de pas laisser
parler les autres pour une fois il va
revenir sur sa vie sur sa célébrité il
va revenir sur le fait de je suis le
fils de il a beaucoup vécu en étant le
fils de Johnny le fils de Sylvie vtan
c'est quand même deux monstres sacrés
c'est compliqué d'exister en tant
qu'artiste alors que voilà il est auteur
compositeur c'est un formidable musicien
donc il a envie de faire connaître et
rappeler qui il est d'où il vient il va
rappeler toute cette période aux
États-Unis où il a vécu avec son poère
Tony Scotti qu'il a aussi élevé puisque
Johnny était quand même un petit peu
adsent mais il va revenir sur ses
relations avec Johnny je pense qu'il y
aura un passage effectivement avec sur
Laeticia mais lui il est pas lié par la
confidentialité mais c'est quelqu'un qui
est extrêmement élégant il ne viendra
pas laver son linge sale en public il
l'a pas fait à l'époque alors qu'il
avait des raisons légitimes de le faire
il ne le fera pas davantage là je pense
qu'il va revenir sur sa vérité sur la
vérité de ses relations avec son papa le
le le le ce qu'on ce qu'on ressent c'est
ça justement c'est c'est plutôt aussi
que la guerre va être lancée et c'est ce
qui fait parler c'est ce qui fait aussi
l'attrait qu'il y a autour de ce livre
miram mais d'ailleurs Laétitia elle est
très en stress hein de la paru par
rapport à la par ah oui bien oui bien
sûr elle est en racera parce que bah
elle se demande s'il va aborder les
histoires d'héritage il va revenir sur
sur l'hommage à La Madeleine si elle va
revenir s'il va revenir sur l'histoire
de l'enterrement à Saint-Bart de la
façon dont elle
aurait éloigné aussi ses enfants aînés
de leur père de la façon dont elle l'a
menti aussi à Johnny c'est quoi c'est
quoi l'histoire c'est quoi parce qu'
elle a elle a elle a quand même souvent
elle a elle a souvent éloigné ça tu
pourras plus en parler parce que tu as
vécu avec eux mais elle a souvent
éloigné Laura et et David de leur père
Laura était obligée de voir son père en
secret en Cimini souvent le personnel
d'ailleurs les aider l'aider pour pour
partir pour aller voir sa fille elle a
aussi souvent dit à Johnny que que David
passait à Los Angeles mais il ne venait
pas le voir alors que c'était pas vrai
donc il y a des choses comme ça sur
lesquelles David risque de revenir et ça
elle le craint
énormément c'est moi ENF de compte j'ai
j'ai vécu différentes périodes une
période américaine avec Johnny et là
effectivement j'ai jamais vu David avec
Johnny à ce moment-là et toute la
tournée 2012-23 où j'ai passé toutes les
dates avec Johnny effectivement David ne
venait que la soirée anniversaire quand
c'était le showud le soir des 70 ans et
là effectivement il se retrouvait il
faisait son truc mais en revanche il y
avait une énorme complicité entre eux et
moi j'ai photographié entre eux des
éclats de rir magnifiques et serrit dans
dans les bras et ça on pouvait paser
qu'ils étaient complices mais c'était
compliqué voyis pas à cause de lticia
c'est de ça qu'elle a peur elle a peur
dans le livre David disent des choses
comme ça bah elle a peur que les gens
oubli qu'il a eu un fils et l'amour
qu'il avait pour pour ses enfants moi je
l'ai vu je l'ai photographié donc on
peut pas on peut pas nier ça la
difficulté c'est qu'il n'a jamais parlé
donc là on va l'écouter on se dit que là
s'il sort du silence c'est pour quelque
chose c'est ça vérité c'est super
voilà c'est ce qui est marrant c'est que
en fait il a commencé à faire du teasing
dès le 13 mai sur sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans et dans l'un de ses
posts il disait j'ai quelques
informations à vous transmettre comme
s'il avait envie voilà de de de révéler
alors je pense pas qu'il va y avoir des
révélations de de de malade mais il y a
quand même des choses qui vont être
révélées où il va avoir envie bah comme
tu le disais de de dire lui comment en
tout cas il a vécu les choses il il en
veut à ltia ah oui il en veut énormément
à ltitia bah de toute façon ça s'est vu
dès la Madeleine lui il a pas aimé tout
le CIRC médiatique c'est quoice qu' nous
on a pas suivi ça c'est quoi le BA par
exemple l'hommage à La Madeleine quand
même tout le monde s'en souvient où on
voit latia arriver derrière la tombe d'à
côté vous avez Laura et David qui sont
un peu plus éloignés ils ont refusé
d'être dans le cortège parce que pour
eux c'était un défilé complètement où
Laeticia se mettait en sc mais surtout
ils nt pas été consultés oui ce que
j'allais dire ils nont pas été ils n'ont
pas été consultés du tout puisque ça
s'est fait entre laetia et puis Brigitte
Macron donc voilà donc ça ça c'est
quelque chose qui leur a beaucoup déplu
et puis après il y a eu à Saint-Bart où
alors il y a des photos où on les voit
se prenant bras dans dans les bras mais
c'est un peu du cinéma parce qu'ils ont
pas voulu partager le même avion à ce
moment-là pour se rendre à l'enterrement
ils ont pas dormi du tout dans la maison
de Johnny à Saint-Bart ils étaient pas
forcément pour non plus l'enterrer à
Saint-Bart même si c'était la volonté de
de Johnny et puis et puis aussi quand
Laeticia elle a fait un un concert
hommage à Johnny en 2021 David a refusé
d'y participer parce qu'il s'est rendu
compte que ce qui tout tout l'argent de
ce concert était censé être donné à des
associations et que au final on s enfin
il s'est rendu compte que ce n'était pas
le cas et que les artistes qui devaient
venir là étaient étai devait le devait
jouer gratuitement alors qu'il y avait
une partie de l'argent c'est pour qui
l'argent bah il y a une partie qui était
à une association et il y a une autre
partie qui a certainement été dans dans
l'un des trust ou que voilà société de
dont bénéficie aujourd'hui Laeticia donc
vous voyez toutes ces choses c'est un
peu des grosses grosses rancœurs qu'on
qu'on les enfants donc je pense que il
se parl jamais il se parl plus du tout
les il se parl plus puis c'est un énorme
regret aussi pour David parce qu'il ne
voit plus ses petite sœur j desj donc il
est très il est très peiné de de ça puis
il y a les derniers moments les derniers
moments ah oui je crois que c'est la
grosse gros difficulté derni ces
derniers moments de Johnny les uns et
les autres disent que selon lestitia
c'est Johnny qui déjà était dans un état
difficile ne voulait pas voir ses
enfants soit 10 ans avec des SMS qui
étaient prétendument envoyé du portable
de Johnny pour dire NON ne venez pas
alors qu'il était pas il était dans
l'incapacité de pouvoir prendre son
portable et envoyer ses messages et donc
les enfants qui ont été empêchés de de
de voir de voir leur Pèdre et de leur
dire au revoir et cette chanson de de
David d'ailleurs je ne luai pas dit au
revoir donc c'est c'est voilà je pense
que c'est là c'est c'est des choses qui
ont été cruciaux je pense dans dans
l'opinion publique quel quelles étaient
les les légitimités des difficult parce
donc elle répondait de son téléphone
elle leur disait oui oui voilà c'est ça
il faisait croire que c'était Johnny
puis surtout ben il a attendu toute la
journée on l'a empêcha d'accéder au
bureau qui servait en fait de de de
chambre d'hôpital pour pour Johnny on
l'a empêchéit d'accéder à ce bureau le
dernier jour le le le dernier jour où
Johnny a rendu son dernier souffle donc
ça a été un vrai traumatisme pour lui et
d'ailleurs Laura c'est comme ça que
c'est que toute l'histoire a commencé a
fait une lettre où elle elle nous
apprenait à ce moment-là que non
seulement son père les avait des hérités
ce qui lui semblait très troublant et
surtout qu'elle n'avait pas pu elle
aussi dire au revoir à son père Renault
mais euh les derniers jours de Johnny
ont été extrêmement difficiles mais moi
j'ai eu un échange de texto avec lui
peut-être 3 semaines avant sa mort donc
il y a c'est les la dernière semaine qui
a été coupée de tout et euh je comprends
c'est c'est normal quand on a envie de
voir son père et qu'on on peut pas
accéder à à la chose la plus importante
au monde et bah forcément ça crée une
cassure à vie c'est ça euh Gill voulez
dire quelque chose vous voulez poser une
question oui je voulais poser une
question sur la la fameuse dette à à
Roland parce que on disait 30 millions
d'euros et en mai là en mai dernier la
dette a été une nouvelle fois repoussée
parce que je crois que la maison de
Marne la coquette enfin cet été elle
n'était pas encore vendue donc c'est
bien ça elle arrive à chaque fois à
renégocier auprès du fisque la la
fameuse dette he en fait auprès du
fisque vous avez une somme en principale
mais la somme en principal a été très
lourdement impacté par toutes les les
intérêts toutes les pénalités de retard
on le voit bien quand on paye pas notre
taxe de foncière on a déjà des pénalités
donc imaginez quand la dette fait
plusieurs millions ce que comment elle
grossit donc à chaque fois on peut
lorsqu'on paye le principal négocier
pour arriver à un montant qui soit un
peu plus conforme à à la dette du et là
comme la maison a du mal à se vendre ben
la négociation se fait voilà en
considération de ça et c'est derilleurs
la raison pour lesquell les enfants et
en tout cas David ne voulaient surtout
pas approcher ce volet fiscal ouais non
c'est vrai que la maison a du mal à se
vendre 10 million et demi d'euros et
encore ils ont baissé le Pr parce que
elle beaucoup plus non elle est toujours
à 10,5 C é elle était à 10 et demi mais
la maison é énorme le terrain est énorme
l'entretien doit être énorme plus il y a
énormément de travaux donc comme comme
la maison est immense le mec qui va
l'acheter non seulement s'il a paye 10
millions il a 3 4 millions de travaux
c'est une maison qui va lui coûter
15 ou mais la copropriété voudra pas
parce qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
d'aller venus donc un musée dans la
maison de Johnny c'est c'est compliqué
c'est tout le monde a pensé à ça voisin
mais ça a été l'idée à un moment donné
mais pas mec non mais je vous dis parce
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de gens qui je
vous dis la vérité il y a beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont appelé même moi pour me
dire est-ce que tu voudrais pas qu'on
achète la maison de Johnny et cetera et
pour lu faire amuser je dis moi j'adoré
Johnny avec plaisir mais il crois qu'ils
sont enseignés c'est vrai qu'avec la
copropriété c'est plutôt compliqué et je
pense que les les voilà les
copropriétaires de la résidence voilà où
ils sont V dire on va pas voir on va pas
voir toute la journée des gens rentrer
et sortir pour aller visiter la maison
de Johnny donc la maison de Johnny
elleelle elle est immense elle est
magnifique mais le problème c'est que
elle est annoncé excessivement cher et
que il y a énormément de travaux à faire
dedans donc c'est une maison qui va qui
va rir combien pour être raisonnable
d'après vous une
estimation 4 millions ce serait combien
la vraie estimation de la maison moi je
suis pas agent
immob non franchement combien peu près 4
millions 4 millions oui je pense elle
est à 10 et demi ça non mais avec ça
c'est avec les voilà c'est normal c'est
c'est avec les les les frais de de
l'agent commercial tout ça non parce que
en fait derrière tu vas avoir 4 5
millions de travaux il faut que la
maison il faut que la maison une maison
à la
trs co mais dans Résid il faut qu' coûte
pas plus de 10 millions si coûte plus de
10 millions tu es sûr et la bouffe c'est
fin donc voilà donc il faut faut qu' 4 5
et que tu fasses 4 5 millions de travaux
pour pouvoir pourquoi j'ai pas compris
pourquoi travau elle était pas au goût
du
jour la piscine par exemple la
piscine un terrain énorme et la maison
est très grande donc forcément quand tu
fais au m Carr si la maison elle fait
1500 m car même si tu fais des travaux
de je sais pas moi à 2000 € du mtre et
ben tu fais ton calcul déjà ça te fait 3
million de travaux 3 million de travaux
tu as payé le notaire tu as payé trucs
tu as tout l'extérieur BIM BIM ça te
coûte 4 5 millions voilà voilà merci
qu'est-ce
qu' c'est vrai Mme non mais voilà ça
c'est c'est c'est c'est voilà tu es
d'accord avec moi moi j'ai déjà été je
connais la maison effectivement elle est
immense mais ça un petit peu vieilli
donc ça demande beaucoup de travaux
évidment donc forcément alors dans ce
livre moi je ne vois pas David ne pas
faire ces révélations que tu nous as
fait vous nous avez fait tous les trois
je le vois pas s'il a écrit c'est qui va
nous raconter les derniers moments de
Johnny sa frustration par rapport au
fait qu'il a il a il a pas vu son père
une dernière fois et qu' lui ait pas dit
il voulait lui dire en revoir
l'enterrement qu'il a pas géré Miriam
c'est sûr qu'on va voir ça oui c'est sûr
mais et puis surtout il va rappeler
quand même les relations que lui avait
avec son père qui n'était pas aussi
désastreuse que Laetitia voulait le
laisser entendre justement latitia les
relations entre ltitia et David elles
ont tout de suite été mauvaises ou pas
non il s'entendait bien au début même
même avecme ave ou bien sûr c'est à
partir de 2009 quand Johnny a été malade
effectivement là le clash parce que
Laeticia a commencé à à reprendre la vie
de Johnny et la carrière de Johnny en
main et à ce moment-là tout a changé
parce que David et ses enfants ont été
squeezés donc là ça a créé vraiment une
session David avait été à Los Angeles
quand son père était était malade à ce
moment-là et qui s'est réveillé du coma
et là effectivement il était déjà
mécontent de tout tous les artistes qui
venaient voir Johnny les gens qui
connaissaient pas a surtout mesuré le
fait que Johnny pouvait disparaître
alors heureusement il est resté encore 8
ans mais elle a mesuré le fait qu'il
pouvait disparaître et que rien n'avait
été prévu donc elle a mis en place de
à le système qu'on conna ce jourl il y a
une énorme dispute entre latia et
davidar l'hôpital où où
était
es où était bon com Johnny le pvre et en
fait il y a eu un énorme clash entre
Laetitia et et David parce que il y
avait il y avait les équipes d'em6 qui
étaiit là il y avait Nico salagas qui
était là il y avait Patrick pruel qui
était là et pour David c'était
inimaginable pour lui c'était un cirque
médiatique et qui n'avait pas lieu
d'être et alors à partir de ce moment-là
ça a étéit les relations entre les deux
c'était fini Merci à VOUS TR merci
ronand merci Renaud B vous reviendrez
nous voir hein pour le livre pas de
problème merci Miriam d'avoir été avec
nous tout de suite c'est le sang de la
vigne sur ces V le sang du sang
[Applaudissements]